liberals suck is what some people might
say you see what I did there now many of
you have heard Nancy Pelosi's claims of
the conservative grassroots movement
this initiative is funded by the high
end we call it astroturf it's not really
a grassroots movement so I decided to
check out what liberals consider to be a
real grassroots movement yes folks I
went undercover as a liberal hold on to
your butts
now I know what you're thinking Stephen
how could you and believe me I know
it is incredibly shameful and my family
disowned me but someone had to do it a
political activism job search on
Craigslist turned up a few
recommendations and before long I was
interviewing for one of Southern
California's premier liberal activist
organizations so I am in the car on the
way to a job interview at CALPIRG and
environment what is it Davis
California's public interest group at
their consumer advocacy group now
remember some of the things you're about
to hear are both shocking and hilarious
this is from oldie capitalism is okay
when it makes nice sweaters not to begin
with all of you silly conservatives need
to know how the right wing's grassroots
really work the second challenge is from
the power of special interests length
but when it comes there it is
big oil companies are paying people of
Shilla their method of operation is to
use their best resources to put their
friends in office and then tell them the
laws the passwords they're in office
astroturf even corporate fat cats paying
people to act as mouthpieces for their
own financial and political gain as
opposed to the liberal grassroots which
works as follows we were crude and we
trained paid staff to go to the door or
into busy public places wait what
this is what these grassroots groups
their money a little bit however it
takes to win raising money to help pay
nonprofit political activist workers but
why he's got a section again we know it
won't last forever so now is the time we
need to push them doing better changes
that we need well to be fair I'm sure
she only meant that to a degree I mean
remember Obama and liberals are all
about unity and reaching across the
aisle we're actually a little less
interested in continuing to try to
pursue the specular
well I guess it doesn't really matter
because they don't have enough votes to
push the public option through anyhow I
was kind of upset because I really we
still didn't have enough Democrats to
vote for that there was still the blue
dog problem today YES on this and we
have 60 hold it okay I can tell some of
your confused thinking wait don't they
need 60 votes to get something through
the Senate now typically in the system
that the founding fathers intended yes
60 votes are needed to overcome a
filibuster at certain budget related
measures can pass with 51 votes through
a parliamentary maneuver called
reconciliation in recent days Democratic
leaders have concluded that they can
pack more of the health care overhaul
plans under this procedure is it
unethical yes has anything this
controversial or polarizing been pushed
through in this manner before no but
that never stops the Democrats after all
they don't answer to greedy corrupt
politicians they're the party of the
people so unless the people don't follow
lockstep with a democratic party and
what choice did they have just look at
how CalPERS feels about the citizens of
California's decision on Prop 8 people
should not get to vote on it it should
be something that our courts decide it's
more democratic that way our schools
know the court said I need to integrate
usuals right not much really well for
Detroit that part still makes me laugh
if only we didn't have to blur out the
faces she was nodding in complete
agreement mmm yeah now Detroit was
clearly a success right can we hear that
one again not much really well for
Detroit back then I mean before things
changed I really thought she was going
to discover me a fraud with that one but
nope apparently she digs Detroit by the
way did you know that Detroit now has a
bear problem as more of the outskirts
get abandoned bears have actually
started moving into the city I mean the
last thing Detroit needs right now is
bears but maybe that's what the Liberals
want to take over the country with bears
mmm perhaps the perfect plan oh the
horror
is there no way
madness Nancy Pelosi okay so I know the
question you're asking now well Stephen
did you get the job so the Saudis works
with 20,000 $40 here helping elderly
benefits package that includes vacation
sick days college loan assistance and
after one year you can join that
volunteer - wait you mean I actually did
get the job you may be thinking but why
would they offer you a salary if it's
nonprofit well let me show you how their
company structure works okay so first
off we've got the student perk right
here okay this mainly consists of
college know-it-all hippies students
who've had their eyes recently open
other their professors things like that
and that's organized by the state perk
or CALPIRG as you see in this video on
this consists of professional paid
lobbyists or dare I say it special
interest groups who are ultimately
organized by what you'll hear commonly
referred to as the fund notice it goes
out of the white board there and I know
you're thinking hey Steven that's a big
circle how much money is in the fund I'm
glad you asked actually over the last 25
years over 400 million dollars have been
raised and donated from the fund to
liberal activist nonprofit organizations
I mean how much money is that really
okay 20 million is five million more
than Big Pharma in 2008 and it's about
the same as the evil auto manufacturers
have given actually sorry over the last
11 cycles so technically while they're a
non-profit they have plenty of capital
and any way you cut it to a college
student such as myself coming in with
literally no resume or experience
it's a profit thirty-three thousand a
year plus benefits is very enticing the
astroturf Tea Party movement isn't
dishing out that kind of dough as a
matter of fact their average salary for
a worker is somewhere around yeah that
sounds about right so now I ask you
which movement do you consider to truly
be grassroots is it the Conservatives
volunteering their time or liberal
organizations like CALPIRG and
vironment California with full-time
salaried employees as always let me know
as for myself I feel great shame and I
need to go wash off the filthy hippie
you know some boys
for more of the raw unedited job
interview be sure to check out the links
at pj tv.com thanks for watching